you have any words of inspiration for
the channel don't rush to move I need
light for my makeup too oh Jesus Christ
holy cow
alright it's 4 40 we're going to take a
bit of a break and go to costco and I
care to buy a few things show you a
quick update master bedroom this is
coming along in this closet coming along
Dean is working a lot how's your back I
like your shirt though kitchen is a mess
but coming along family room we got the
couch set up TV coming along tons of
boxes dumped down dunt dunt down off
pass this are going to hang those up I'm
going to put a stand-up desk here I got
a place to show off my youtube then
going to put some other things on here
got a nice plant closet gotta still sort
out we're going to costco for what
hangers i'm going to get that stand up
desk from ikea it's the motorized one
you can push up and down what else do we
need all the little cushiony things that
you can push furniture on you have any
words of inspiration for the channel
don't rush to move did we rush to move
we didn't rush well more than normal I
think we did pretty well compared the
most equal we got movers movers are
amazing though movers are worth it
Mickey would move all this ourselves
would be dead and then wrap it up and
get a good job Kip movers ok Opta costco
and ikea
need I know I injured myself tonight
sure I believe you're tired but we got
up at five or something goodbye it's
crazy I normally hate going to costco
it's among my least favorite things to
do in life actually any kind of shopping
grocery shopping but I need hangers for
my closet and I want them to be amazing
so I'm excited I want my father to be
like I open it up and it's Batman I want
to be inspired by my closet daily the
act of opening up my closet inspiration
this is it we found the hangers non-slip
hangers you can touch it Nina you okay
name is sneezing up a storm bill the
velvety ones I like the wooden ones
better though two boxes
what is that we have that no you don't
like him okay get them you ordered that
online at Amazon sure he'll do one yeah
me three sure I like it silver looks
good chrome what might give me that look
what does that look for okay let's go
wait now explain the look yes you sound
like just to wrap it up late know what
do you call that I don't know just quit
I don't care yeah I know they're good
they're good they're there they're
definitely one better than the plastic
ones i like it i don't mean I don't care
so much about toilet bowl cleaners but
you know if you had to go with one you
go metallic next up is ikea so do we
doing here we're looking for better
hangers potentially light bulbs the
things that slide under the furniture
and the stand up gents this is it this
is the black version we're gonna get the
white one though
this is it let's write it down what do
you think baby name is tired and you
want to what only gonna be standing
that's right friends so the good news is
they have it the bad news is they don't
have it in the store so we've got to go
to a different location to go pick it up
so we're going to finish our shopping
see what else we need to buy so I can
get my desk go home and build it Nina
needs a new pan frying pan what kind of
pain you need you want to buy that one
you need taller than this this is pretty
tall now to the pants moving up the
lighting section IKEA has no daylight
LED bulbs are all soft so they have
together we looked which I do not want
so we are striking out all over idea no
pot for Nina but we got the desk I know
it's not here
lights for me are you doing are you
farming I think we need a big son and
your gloves disco ball look at that
immediate makeups important I need light
for my makeup too haha we found the felt
tip pads tiny how many do you need how
many do you need
Oh put in the bank any first thing to go
in the bag success hooray any time Nina
has a chance to look at plane stuff she
goes all in no Basil's yummy
no such a big so our big trip to ikea
resulted in this being purchased plus
the stand-up desk all right on our way
and it's got the pots now the real
question is are we going to get a hot
dog or some ice yeah I'm gonna admit I'm
a little bit size a little bit here
coming down but it's okay well get the
desk and then go get for real dinner all
right here it is I'm going to take it
hope and build it you ready Nina you
farming Nina farming don't don't run
into the wall
we don't want any night to get hangry
and she's been very patient all day and
very hungry right now so we're going to
go try out a new korean place called
June's because Nina wants some tofu soup
I'm gonna get some bulgogi and i might
go get a oreo mcflurry afterwards I
might maybe the bulgogi that I get will
be covered in oreo mcflurry if a guy
don't need any more so the food was just
ok we're going to go to mcdonalds I did
I wasn't sure if we're going to go
well I said maybe they'll have oreo
mcflurry on top of my devotee
there was no oreo mcflurry on top of my
cookies so we're going to go get our
glory with caramel needs me over the
park oh because it's going to run it oh
right there you go mean it Nina's going
to go to the car cruising run out of
parking so I'm going to get large oreo
mcflurry with caramel sauce possible
action but so so so something
which isn't like sweet stuff so
little surprise for anyway what
surprised the life right
it's the thought that counts maybe like
that
hi Oh
all I maclerie okay she just that kind
of get her one to see I wanted to
surprise her but I'm going to get her
the same thing
I like the new system easy oh Jesus
cross holy cow are you farming again
well I'm waiting for you ok here take
this and take this let me tell you
something so I was walking down the
street and I stained you had left right
and i said i should i get something for
Nina and then I said it's nice to
surprise the wife right you got to
surprise her and get or something and
then I said but she doesn't like things
that are sweet so I got to find
something that's not too sweet and even
if he doesn't eat it's a thought that
counts about husband you know buying
something nice for her and I thought
maybe I'll get her an apple pie but I'm
gonna go look at the menu and then like
five seconds later hey Harry can you
give me one too I couldn't surprise you
but it's a thought that counts and it's
on video and you'll see it so husband
was thinking about you and then he
scared you yeah ok let's go home build a
table
I'm going to build the table I'm very
excited
you